being obese is not healthy
it's not healthy
you are entitled to make that decision
if you you know you're overweight
you want
you like the way you look you like the
way you feel
everybody has their and also let me be
clear this is not a conversation about
personal preferences everyone has a type
that they're attracted to
everyone finds something different
beautiful what i might like tyler might
not like what we might like someone else
might not like this is not about
personal preferences in terms of what
you find beautiful or attractive we're
talk i'm exclusively
exclusively talking about health here
being obese is not healthy we saw during
covet 19 particularly that one of the
comorbidities that put people at a
higher risk for getting sick was obesity
that's a fact that's just a fact not
about feelings again
cosmopolitan
ran a couple of campaigns this year
on this topic and they put a couple of
covers out there tyler i don't know if
you have those
this is also from the post millennial
but these are cosmo features here's some
examples
there's an article that's titled
cosmopolitan calls obesity healthy
during the pandemic of all times by the
way and it shows two covers where they
actually say
on the covers
this is healthy
and it features two images of women who
are clearly obese and it interviews them
and goes about this whole discussion
about
well you know i've always been boxed out
because i didn't fit you know the
definition of help listen
again
this isn't this this this should not
what cosmopolitan should be doing if
they really care about health
is saying and here are the images that
you can see there
i see what they're doing here right they
want you to this is embracing everyone
make everybody feel good make everybody
feel it's about feelings right this is
about making you feel a certain way
maybe you're upset because the typical
traditional definitions of health show a
lot of fit women you know show a lot of
thinner women maybe that bothers you
let it bother you enough to say
this isn't healthy i'm going to do
something about it every single person
out there has an ability to do something
positive for their health
it's a choice in many respects i
understand there are thyroid conditions
there are some medical conditions that
come into play here that make things a
lot harder obviously for the vast
majority of people
lifestyle choices play an enormous role
in what goes on here
my concern here is that
why is this being glorified as healthy
why
why why do we have to change the
definition of reality which is that
being obese is not a healthy decision we
know obesity puts you at greater risk of
heart disease obesity puts you at
greater risk of stroke obesity
puts you at greater risk of chronic
illness of of many things in life that
not being obese
doesn't
this is just fact you can talk to to
doctors you can talk to holistic doctors
you can and you know it right people
know this this is a reality that people
know
what happens is when you point this out
when you when you look at images these
are the images that you've just seen
if you say something about it you're
called fatphobic
you're called hateful
you're called judgmental when in reality
what i really want sitting here is i
want magazines i want the medical
community i complain throughout the
entire covet
pandemic i do this sometimes pandemic
because we need to look at the numbers
on that too we'll get to that
but throughout the entire time i was
like where is the talk about health
real health i'm not talking about big
pharma drugs coming to the rescue jab
number 65
still get covered but jab number 65 i'm
talking about real health i'm talking
about setting up yourself for you're
going to face viruses in your life
you're going to face bacteria in your
life you're going to encounter
things put yourself in the best body you
can to encounter those things i'm
talking about food real whole food not
the synthetic meat that bill gates would
love you to eat by the way
talking about real you know farm-raised
meat
i'm talking about you know fruits and
vegetables
i'm talking about dietary changes
exercise meditation
stress
we all know that's a killer we all know
it
but very few of us manage it i'm not
good at managing stress i do my best but
very few of us prioritize it in life we
just go through the grind of life why
was nobody talking about that so what i
would love to see cosmo do
if they're really concerned with health
as they claim
is to focus on this to point out the
reality that obesity is a detriment to
your health but there are things that
you can do about it
you don't have to be a victim of that
you don't have to be a victim of
anything
you can decide
and here and we're going to help you
we're going to give you some tools we're
going to talk to doctors we're going to
talk to people real nutritionists who
really know what they're doing we're
going to break down what you could do
right as opposed to what you're doing
wrong we're going to give tips no
that's not what they did instead they
chose to glorify something that's not
good for people if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]